The Last of Us was like the best year of
my life and it's not going to be the
same so I just have to like go into it
being like this is season two and I
loved season one but this is just gonna
be different
okay fella Ramsay is with us right now
yes Bella Ellie herself Bella thank you
so much for joining us today well of
course thank you for having me and I my
cat is joining uh you can't see him
because it's quite dark but he's gonna
be a part of this because he is
incredibly old incredibly needy coming
off the heels of last week which was
like the DLC what did you learn about
Ellie from that backstory from that DLC
and seeing her relationship with Riley I
just love there's this moment where
Riley gets out the five dollar bill and
Ellie's like kind of says like oh have
you done this with anybody else before
essentially and I was like that is me
that was me as a teenager
yeah I mean that's that's really funny
that you say that
um
yeah I mean I think that episode was
really just about like what it was like
for Ellie before like she
I mean like the experience at the end
like the first time she's experienced
loss at the end of that episode and then
like obviously that continues and
continues and continues like once she
begins this journey but yeah this this
took place I think they say like three
weeks before Ellie first meets Joe so I
think it's just really cool to have that
backstory and like
um to see what Ellie was like before all
of this and before she knew she was
immune and like just existing and having
a crush on her best friend and like how
that plays out I just think it's cool
and it ties in really well to uh
relationship with Joel to make the point
that they're at I love that HBO Max
tweeted the best friend stare with like
you guys looking at each other and I was
like okay best friends
friends history will say they're a
roommates yes
I that episode last week on the on on
our show we were talking about you know
we have we all have our imagination of
what happened after the Riley and Ellie
story ended in the show and in the game
and at the same point they had the
choices and then it doesn't really tell
us what happens next what do you think
as some you know the person who is
embodying Ellie you are Ellie what do
you think happened uh do you do how do
you think about that
yeah I did think about that quite a lot
um because it also was gonna inform like
how
uh Ellie is going forwards I don't know
like depending on the level of trauma
like it's gonna be it's gonna be
different but there was conversations
that happened around that actually and
um I think we sort of agreed
um I don't know what to say because it's
like
I think it's up to people's imaginations
really but from our point of view I
think Ellie probably had to make a
really hard
decision and do something I really
didn't want to do and experience
great loss make that links back to that
scene in an episode
or possibly uh I lose track of the
episodes um where she's like it wasn't
my first time
oh yeah
same somebody and yeah like that this
time of Ben Riley possibly that's what I
was thinking and then the whole
survivor's Guild of her probably just
going through this whole thing and being
like why am I not turning what is going
on like I just and even like being kept
in the dark with it makes it so much
more
I don't know if we ever did like
explicitly agree and I think it's it's
it's
more powerful that it's kept like
unspoken and kept to people's
imaginations because I think the
imagination can often be like darker
than reality yeah
geez sorry
anyone else shows up I put one right
between my eyes
that's right this is the part of the
game where it's the first time we play
as Ellie because Joel got impaled so
this like so this week and last week
you're kind of like you're you're in
this show without Pedro like it's it's
this is Ellie kind of on your own how
was it did it change does the set change
does the experience the expectation the
day change when it when there is no jolt
around how does that change the energy
for you
it completely changes it like suddenly I
was
my whole National experience has been so
tired to Pedro so to like then
find like how to
like I don't know how to function on set
without him was weird
um I had withdrawal symptoms from being
around him all the time and his stupid
jokes and playing Xanadu
um on his phone endlessly
um so it was uh yeah it was a weird
change and I missed him I really really
missed him
um which I think actually worked like
for them to the episode and it was just
it made me also appreciate it even more
when he was back I'm like oh yeah I've
missed you
Pedro wasn't there but the original Joel
Miller Troy Baker was I'm curious what
that experience like was like for you I
think me and Troy had this immediate
respect for each other because I had
seen bits of the game
um and
he was obviously coming onto the show
and it was um it was actually really it
was a really special experience meeting
him for the first time and being like
it's like that Spider-Man meme where
it's like
yeah it felt like that
um uh but I didn't I didn't really know
how much we talked about
the uh like I think he he was basically
encouraging me that I was it was Ellie
you know and um
I was like equally as
um and in awe of his a job and I think
we just like wandered over that a little
bit we didn't talk about it a lot we
didn't pick each other's brains we just
sort of like I think it is a new thing
he was singing your Praises when we
interviewed him we have a little a
little message from Troy who who has who
wants to share his thoughts on how
things went down in this episode
I'm terrified taught me in the neck dude
in the neck in the neck
and
that scene was a lot longer
so my next question is to Craig
we'll talk about
it he
got and how many times they had to reset
the blood bag and all that stuff but so
how many times did you have to kill the
original Joe Miller on set
quite a lot of tires I just remember him
walking around it's like acting his neck
all day and also me being so uh like
desensitized to like all of this and
just being like Oh Troy hasn't actually
his neck like it didn't it's a problem
of like growing up in this industry you
really become desensitized to things
like that
um that was a long day it just kept
going and going and going and going and
I think Troy was even there like they
had to do a little insert shot I think
of him after yeah I killed I killed
original Joel quite a few times but he
was like he was on the he was like gonna
murder me and like eat me so I think
it's fine I think it was justified I
think it was justified do you think that
like how does this kind of change Ellie
and then if if at all now that because
that that reunion maybe Joel expected
more of an Embrace and it comes but it's
it's at this horrific moment and what do
you think this kind of like
what happens now
oh that's a big question uh yeah I mean
it's definitely a like she's
experienced
traumas before but like this is like
nothing that she's ever experienced I
don't think she ever insisted like of
all the things that could have gone
wrong in this world like all the time
she could have died up until now like
she did not
anticipate this
um I think she is
she she
is also scared not only of like what
happened with with David and
what was what he was going to do to her
but she's also I think maybe more afraid
of what she did to him and that violence
that lives within her I don't think that
she's
we see how it actually punched Bethany
in the face in the last episode and like
we've seen her be violent but not like
this like this is
uh and I think that's that
guess her like what she's capable of she
killed David probably within like the
first two hacks of the ax to his face
and she just kept going and kept going
and kept going and it felt good
um in the same way that like Joel was
beating that guy to death it was like he
didn't have to do that
um
it sort of
yeah I don't know it's a lot what has
been your favorite reactions to the show
so far I'm very well I have like it's
like a
a gay army you were like super on
Twitter who are just like supporting me
and Ellie and it's like there
so much louder than any people who still
hate it or hate the show like the
homophobic trolls whatever and it's just
like that feels nice to just have like
um that Army but I mean that's been a
reaction that I've really enjoyed
um and also just people being like uh
I like I love um Gamer's reactions to
the show like that's the thing that
feels the most validating is when like
Gamers beloved uh uh Gamers who are so
invested in the game to then
say like this is
so good and it lives up all my
expectations and exceeds them like
that's the thing that's the reaction
that feels
like
really really cool have you seen it's
like the meme it's it's Joel and Ali in
the game and Joel's wearing a shirt this
is I love my lesbian daughter
oh yeah
oh and actually you know to answer your
question better like it's all the memes
that have come out of it oh the meme
reactions that people are doing like
there was one the other day that I loved
um after the episode seven where it's
like Ellie game Ellie has her hands in
her head and she's like I'm so gay
um and I I just love them I love people
like rehashing game the game memes to
like react to the show and as a takeaway
from the fun of being a fan uh but I do
I do have to ask you about this episode
this show specifically you talk about
the reactions to it has any any of the
episodes stood out to you as like
memorably challenging emotionally to get
through what has been the toughest one
for you to like look at and be like wow
Ellie's got to go through this I have to
perform this
episode 8 for sure this one no question
yeah yeah this one
um it's just the most intense like it's
Ellie surviving without
Joel and surviving before Joel and
enduring so much pain beforehand
um yeah and and it was cold like it was
emotionally and physically this was like
the toughest episode uh for sure but I
loved it like I had a great time
um but yeah it was I remember reading
the script and I actually have videos of
me reading the script for the first time
because I was so it's a sort of funny
story I was really concerned that my
American accent wasn't American anymore
because I'd like got so used to it so
it's like I'm gonna record myself
reading this episode out loud so that I
can listen back and see if I sound
American and then it just turned into me
like life reacting to them the the crazy
that I was reading and uh I have them
somewhere I I dread I don't think I've
never watch them back but I remember the
first time I realized reading the script
that like these guys were cannibals I
was like what it was yeah
I want to see those yeah if you don't
want to watch them we will
[Laughter]
maybe one day you guys are all wrapped
up on season one and season two renewal
we're all so excited to hear about are
you like how did how do you get ready to
go back to work and do this again are
you what how are you feeling about that
I'm really excited uh it it still feels
surreal to me that it's gonna
go again
um but also I'm going into it with the
ex like I don't want to go into it
comparing it to the uh experience the
first season because I'm like that
that's never gonna like season one is
The Last of Us was like the best year of
my life and it's not gonna be the same
so I just have to like go into it being
like this is season two and I loved
season one but this is just gonna be
different
foreign